if there's one thing that's been clear
to me since I started playing the closed
beta for the crew it's that this is a
ubisoft game through and through it
takes place in a large and lavishly
produced world stuffed with things to do
it sends you from location to location
dizzying you with tasks that seem only
vaguely related to the goals of the
story this is entertainment for easily
distracted people like me the
distractions are built into the very
experienced the game itself distracting
me from itself with another way point
another goal another vehicle to drive
it's a formula that works but it's also
a formula that toes the line between
keeping you busy and making you feel
like you're just going through the
motions and based on the crew beta I'm
not sure that the game will land on the
proper side of that line but I can't
deny its appeal it all began from almost
the moment I signed into the game and
the initial chase sequence roared ahead
from there I've gone to Detroit to
Chicago to st. Louis to New York and
places in between chasing missions and
other tasks that earn me new Parts that
spruce up my two current vehicles of
ford mustang and the Ford Focus I also
are in perk points that I can spend on
upgrades that provide boosts like
experience bonuses I pursue the
waypoints I perform tasks like chasing
down rival gang members or rushing
someone to another section of the map
and I earn a reward it's you chasing and
it's compelling in that primal way that
games like diablo so often our ends like
in an action RPG i'm not necessarily
alone in the world i wouldn't call the
crew a massively multiplayer game but
you still share your gameplay session
with others and you can join up with
them to roam cities and the stretches in
between if you don't know way of these
folks and considering the crew uses you
play as its social portal you probably
won't
you can invite nearby players to join
you whenever you activate a mission
conversely you'll frequently receive
random requests to join others in their
own cooperative tasks afterwards you and
your crew can roam about together or you
can disband this structure means you can
easily hop from place to place provided
you've already driven once to the area
you're visiting occasionally I bounced
around from one city to another using
the quick travel system but I enjoyed
driving across the beautiful stretches
of Midwestern farms and towns even
though those expenses are far smaller
than their real life counterparts I mean
I drove from Chicago to New York in
about ten minutes after all in time
however the beta has proven somewhat
unsatisfying even after just a few hours
the never-ending quest for more powerful
cars aside there's not much to tie the
crew beta together I suppose the story
as Ubisoft's attempt to ground the crew
in a theme but at least in the beta it's
absolute nonsense full of ridiculous
dialogue and dumb story beats but
without the gung-ho silliness that could
have made it mindless fun as for the
driving I admit I'm spoiled by need for
speed rivals slick handling in the crew
beta of vehicles don't behave
consistently sometimes careening off of
the smallest objects as if they've
bounced from a trampoline making contact
with other vehicles doesn't always
result in the collision you expect but
rather might send you ricocheting away
as if the cars were covered with a thick
layer of rubber there's undoubtedly
plenty of time to tune up the physics of
horse but it was hard not to notice the
quirks in the crew beta the driving is
serviceable it's the sheer variety of
tasks and the constant call to group up
to go to a different city to do one of a
dozen available challenges that keeps
you on the move that said I'm really
looking forward to seeing how the crew
blossoms is the game nears its full
release this November it's a big n ultra
detailed game that in its current beta
state comes across as a bit random and
unfocused but a few major tune-ups could
make the crew an appealingly smooth ride
one that you could put a lot of miles on